9/11 was no doubt one of the most
devastating events in history claiming
the lives of almost 3,000 victims
permanently damaging a lot of their
families and friends this instant has
single-handedly changed the course of
history filling the war on terror
costing the u.s. $20 and ushering in a
new era of secured in fear against
Muslims but what if the US are somehow
able to anticipate these attacks and
stop them what if one of the most
pivotal moments in history never took
place
what if 9/11 never happened first of all
as you guys probably already know
September 11th wasn't the first time
terrorist groups have tried to take down
at twin towers in 1993 a terrorist group
placed a truck bomb in the North Tower
of the World Trade Center the plan was
to destabilize in North Tower and sent
it crashing into the South Tower killing
thousands of people
fortunately the plan failed but the
danger was real as it killed six people
injured over a thousand what's even
scarier is that some experts claimed
that if the bomb was placed closer to
the foundation of the building it may
have very well worked so clearly
terrorist groups had their eyes on the
World Trade Center for a while and as
sad as it is if 9/11 didn't take place
they probably would have continued to
plot other ways to take down the
building but as for the effects of 9/11
I think these affects me grouped into
four major groups political economic
social and global starting with
political repercussions President Bush
would have launched a war on terror the
following day
initiating attacks in Afghanistan and
Iraq 27 months later on December 13 2003
Saddam Hussein may have not been
captured and we may see a policy of
containment of the Hussein regime
similar to North Korea today at the same
time this overthrow may have still
occurred as that fear of Iraq building
weapons of mass destruction were at an
all-time high at the time but anyways
while it is toh very controversial
whether or not Hussein's capture was
good for a rock or not this was
definitely a victory for the US and the
war on terror as claimed by President
Bush furthermore the swift action after
9/11 established him as a leader and
instill a sense of security among US
citizens without this victory in Iraq
Bush would have had a very tough time
waited 2004 election as he won
very narrow margin even with this just a
single swing state like Florida going
over to the Democratic Party would have
led to a democratic victory for John
Kerry
so without 9/11 President Bush would
have probably not been reelected on top
of this considering that this election
would have been more focused on the
economy rather than controlling
extremism John Kerry may have not been
the Democratic nominee either as his
Vietnam War background wouldn't have
helped him secure the nomination
remember his famous quote I'm John Kerry
now I'm reporting for duty
[Applause]
anyways following this in the 2008
election we probably would have seen
John Kerry or the winning Democrats
secure the nomination once again so
Obama would have remained a senator from
Illinois there wouldn't have been an
African American president and no birth
controversy either and as the election
itself we wouldn't have seen it to
landslide victory for the Democrats
following that considering two
consecutive Democratic presidents 2,080
camera session and the fact our sama bin
Laden the most wanted terrorist in the
world would have been killed by a
Democratic president we may have very
well seen Mitt Romney win the 2012
election following this Donald Trump
wouldn't have entered a 2016 election as
he wouldn't have a chance against Mitt
Romney running for reelection so unless
Donald Trump went for the Democratic
nomination we wouldn't see Donald Trump
in the political landscape at all moving
back we wind up seeing the passage of a
slew of laws and regulations inspired by
9/11 from the aviation and
Transportation Security Act leading to
TSA to the creation of the US Department
of Homeland Security but consuming the
rampant threats and global terrorist
attacks these acts would have eventually
been passed as for economic consequences
these can be felt to this very day
starting off fifty five billion dollars
wouldn't have been lost on a day 9/11
happened of that 24 billion was the
expected income of the lives lost eight
billion was the World Trade buildings
themselves and computers furniture and
cars cost six billion another six
billion would go to utilities and
subways five billion for injury
treatments and finally in five billion
and other
damaged but that is just the immediate
cost that would have been avoided the
stock market was close to September 17
2001 and when it reopened the Dow
promptly fell seven point one three
percent fortunately though this would
recover by October furthermore their
airline industry wouldn't have lost five
billion dollars of which 1.4 billion
came from the afford a shutdown and
three point six Bank came from the
reduced air travel over the following
year and of course Wars by no means
cheap and this led to a sharp increase
in debt over the years the US would end
up spending two point five trillion
dollars on the war on terror one point
six four nine trillion dollars directly
went into war funding with 867 billion
dollars and expected better his care
this along with the five hundred and
eighty nine billion dollars used by
Homeland Security and the economic and
physical damage toll would come out a
total of three point three trillion
dollars in our alternate timeline on the
cost of Homeland Security would have
still eventually came to be but even
then it would have been much cheaper as
it would have been a gradual increase in
spending rather than a sudden friend an
increase where money was definitely
spent in effectively in the end experts
estimate that 9/11 increase in national
debt by at least two trillion dollars so
without 9/11 the u.s. debt would be 19
trillion or less meaning that it would
be less than a current national gross
domestic product it's not all bad though
the increased us spending created
hundreds of thousands of jobs today
the TSA alone has 51,000 employees with
the Department of Homeland Security
having more than 240,000 employees so at
least 300,000 jobs wouldn't have been
created to a much later if ever
as a result without 9/11 the u.s. debt
would be trillion is lower but the GDP
may not be as high either without these
jobs next the most important effect the
repercussions on the American people
first of all 2996 people wouldn't have
unnecessarily lost their lives and over
6,000 people wouldn't have to sustain
injuries there wouldn't have been
nationwide fear in writing planes for
several months and we wouldn't see
nearly as much fear and hatred towards
Islamic people thousands of families
wouldn't have been separated as family
members headed to war in the Middle East
and that's just affect inside a mirror
things were no better for American
soldiers overseas nearly 7,000 US troops
will be killed in Iraq and Afghanistan
while aggressive war was the best way
the US could cope with the atrocities
committed by certain people in these
countries it is worth mentioning that
200,000 civilians in Iraq 38,000 in
afghanistan and 23,000 in pakistan
wouldn't have died either furthermore
America's crackdown on immigration and
deportations after 9/11 simply wouldn't
have happened according to ABC News
deportations doubled from 2001 to 2012
with criminal deportations increasing by
400% and that brings me into the global
changes in a world without 9/11 of
course there's international airport
security the implementation of TSA
across the US has set the global
standard for airport security but other
than that we saw the Arab Spring this
was a series of anti-government protests
uprisings and armed rebellions that
became rampant across North Africa in
the Middle East
in early 2010 while the overthrowing of
such oppressive regimes is inevitable
this pie would have been delayed for
several more years for instance the euro
sama bin Laden was killed by the u.s.
and Pakistan three brutal middle-eastern
dictatorships were also removed - by
unarmed civil resistance tactics and one
by NATO assisted armed rebellion without
the overthrowing of Iraq and the Global
War on Terror people in these countries
wouldn't have gained the conference to
repel this early on top of that China
may very well not be as big as it is
today looking back at the early 2000s
relations with China were at the very
least not peachy
remember in April of 2001 when a US spy
plane collided with the Chinese fighter
jet in the South China Sea which led to
12 days of tense standoff between the
two countries while monumental at the
time these conflicts were quickly
forgotten amid the tragedy of 9/11 but
in our parallel universe
Chinese conflicts would have remained
just as tense and we may have never seen
the rise of China as a superpower which
has resulted in a sort of economic cold
war today the great Chinese firewall may
have not grown to block basically every
American website and we may have not
seen trade wars escalate to all-time
highs finally without 9/11 the Islamic
state coupe wouldn't have grown to
become nearly as big sure
without 9/11
their leader Osama Bin Ladin may have
not been killed thus leading to more
terrorist attacks but despite the loss
of their leader the 9/11 attacks showed
extremists that they were capable of
causing unforgettable terror to even the
strongest country in the world and this
alone is more motivating for extremists
than one person like Osama bin Laden
ever could be there is no denying that
terrorism has been exponentially growing
ever since 2001 going from under 2000
attacks in 2001 to over 15,000 attacks
in 2014
fortunately however these attacks peaked
in 2014 and we have been on a decline
since but without a quote massively
successful attack for al Qaeda the reach
of the group wouldn't have grown so
rapidly causing even more worldwide
disaster overall 9/11 has touched
everyone's life around the world in one
way or another from having to deal with
more acts of terrorism like 2008 Taj
Hotel attack and 2016 bestowed the
attack on France 2 smaller acts that are
just as significant it has also entered
simple everyday inconvenient but
necessary security measures like
increased airport security but more
importantly as uniting the globe on a
skill never before seen to combat
terrorism from their valiant efforts of
the passengers on United Airlines flight
93 preventing a crash into White House
to thousands of soldiers risking their
lives every day for the well-being of
mankind as a halt
and the thing is as I said in the
beginning even if 9/11 was prevented the
terrorists would have continued trying
over and over again but maybe just maybe
after preventing 9/11 we could have
stopped them before they were able to
succeed with anything on such a grand
scale unfortunately though we can't
change what has happened already and as
a result while 9/11 is a tragedy that
didn't need to occur I believe that as
man is all much stronger moving forward
but that's just what I think what do you
guys think and before you comment
anything let me just say I know this
video wouldn't have been made if 9/11
didn't happen but anyways if you guys
like this video they mix up a like and
consider subscribing if they see more
videos just like this one but Uncle then
I'm Mari and I'll see you guys on the
next one